former rangers everton and scotland
manager walter smith has died at the age
of 73 they'll be best remembered for his
achievements at ibrox where he won 21
trophies during two spells in charge and
led the club to the uefa cup final in
2008. rangers chairman douglas park
described him as much more than just a
football manager he said he was a leader
an ambassador and most of all a legend
let's speak to sky sports news reporter
mark benstead who's in glasgow for us
hello to you mark a sad day there
what have fans been reflecting on today
yeah good afternoon for my brock siri it
is a very very sad day and i think for
all connected with scottish football
particularly so if you're a
member of the rangers family if i should
call it that i think fans are out today
a little bit numb at the moment at the
news um still taking it in getting
getting it through their heads computing
yet some have already turned out here to
pay their tributes i think they're
reflecting on walter smith the man the
way in which he represented this
football club but also the huge success
he brought to it you touched on it there
were ten league titles six scottish
league cups five scottish cups
and the two spells in which he did help
bring success to the club first he came
in his assistant to graham soonest in
1986 he helped them win the club's first
league title in nearly a decade then
after not winning the title the
following year embarked them on this
fantastic journey to nine successive
championships when he came back in for
his second spell he came in when the
club's in a bit of disarray they'd had a
french manager polar glen it hadn't
worked he came back stabilized the club
and he subsequently won three more
championships as you say there was
success as well in europe he took into
that 2008 uefa cup file against senate
saints petersburg they almost got to a
champions league final as well in 1992
pipped in the group stages by eventual
winners marseille so they're reflecting
on all of that and i guess just what it
was like to have a man at the helm of
the football club who believed in the
club supported the club as much as them
it's not just the rangers fans of course
who will feel this one it's his former
players
we've tried to speak to a lot of his
former colleagues and his former squad
members and most of them are just in
bits
they are tearful they can't bring
themselves to come and speak to us
because they hit so hard
by the passing of walter i think
that kind of underlines the kind of guy
he was he had a stern outer outer front
you want to call it that he always
seemed quite abrupt sometimes sometimes
he's brought with guys like me in the
media but the guys who worked with him
and worked for him absolutely loved him
and this is hitting them very hard
indeed today it's also worth pointing
out he had
you know success elsewhere he had time
with the scottish national team who's
assistant to alex ferguson he woke up in
86 he was the manager in his own right
as well coming in after
the country was in a bit of a mess under
bertie vogels he made an impact though
but of belief and stability back to the
national side as well so his passing
today won't just be felt here at ibrox
it will be felt across the whole of
scotland
mark thank you